them in judgment as we face the tasks
before us and enable us now and always
worthily to dispatch to
the sacred trust
placed by the people in our hands
i mean
any others
what would they be received
i'll move that
i'd say that you wish
it's moved and seconded
[Music]
put it to the boat all in favor say aye
aye
against clara carried
declaration of interest anything
new there
all right
public forum
twist
here uh major late items that to be
discussed in
the public excluded session
you worship there's one major light item
to be discussed in public excluded and
that's the chief executive's performance
for review and i'll move that be
accepted
i'll second that your worship
thank you it's been moved and seconded
through received the
performance review of the chief
executive
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
the reason this
item is
not on the agenda
as it is
it was not uh really in time
of the publication of the agenda
reason
why the
discussion
of the item cannot be delayed so the
matter can be progressed
in a timely manner
um
minutes of meeting of the council held
on the 24th of may
2022
i've moved as you worship
[Music]
cancer rabbits
minutes of the extraordinary meeting
of the performance policy
and partnership committee held on the
24th of may
the movie received your worship
second lap
moved and seconded it
put it to the vote all in favor oh
any further discussion on that item
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
carried
minutes of the infrastructural services
committee meeting held
on the 7th of june
2022
yes i'll move that the minutes be
received and also the recommendations
be adopted and that is in respect to the
omnibus reserves amendment for the
tisbury reserve
now there's two recommendations there
it's their second but they receiving
those minutes
yusu
moved and seconded thank you answer the
ladle
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
just sorry your worship um i did have a
comment to make on on those minutes yes
certainly um it's just regarding the
cctv um
it has in the notes that um the next
step was for an investment logic map
process to take place but um
i'm just wondering when the first
committee meeting of that uh since we've
now allocated two councillors that to
that committee i just wondered when the
first meeting of that would be
i did see
some action in that field
that project
through your worship i can answer that
question
uh
counselor i am awaiting mr russell
pearson to provide me with the exact
date he is finalizing the members
of the working group that would be
involved and once we have that
information we will distribute it as
soon as possible
well okay so we haven't finalised the
committee it's finalizing who exactly
the retailers that could be involved as
well
okay
right
that's the first question mr um
in addition to that counselor passenger
no no no no no start at the very
beginning
minutes of risk and
assurance committee held on the 14th of
june 2022. worshiping sorry councillor
bottinger i think interrupted you mid
putting of that motion so for the
purposes of completeness could you
please go back and put the motion
relating to that infrastructure services
committee meeting and those
recommendations
you didn't get the opportunity to
put it
okay so who should i start i think if
you i think everybody knows the motion
that i'm referring to
if you just put that motion now
i'll put that to emotion all in favor
say aye aye
against harry
thank you
the minutes of the risk and assurance
committee held on the 14th of june 2022
to be moved at the minutes of the risk
and insurance committee meeting held on
the 14th of june
he received
i'll move your worship
take a nap
moved and seconded put it to the boat
all in favor say aye aye again carried
the minutes of the performance and
policy and partnership committee
meeting held on the sporting
i've
there was a there was a second meeting
and i'm happy to move that the minutes
are received although
obviously rhiannon and trudy would like
to speak to an item in it that will come
up i think we're voting on the setting
of the rates
shortly
uh through you your worship uh
we adopted the dog control fees that had
been set out in the fees and charges
unfortunately our finance team have been
stretched at capacity and have not been
able to get to any review of just any
discrepancies
in the dog reserve and understanding our
uh animal control accounts so
we
can
keep the dog fees at the 21 22 year
the risk would be if there's potential
budget overspend
or if uh that means an increase in the
future but that option is available and
staff believe that would be the best
course of action for this year
if supported by council
so you worship if i can
speak to that
at the committee meeting there was a
reasonable amount of debate around the
reserves around uh the amounts that sat
in them
and and whether or not
um
the
impact of
an increase of fees was
fairly
placed on
dog owners who were paying their
registration
we needed to recognize as well that
there were risks and increasing numbers
of those who were unable to meet
registration costs
and we were seeking some clarity um
around some of the financials
not being able to get clarity
and now having the option of because we
can't increase
things above what we consulted at but
being able to peel them back
and leave them
where they were for the 21 22 year i
think gives us the same outcome that we
have for
cooper's creek and that there's stuff
that we still need to understand it's
still a work in progress
and
and leaving the fees where they are is
uh is a good option
um i think it gives us a chance to to
get that clarity we will have the
opportunity
leading into the next um long-term plan
process to review
the amount of public good i think that's
factored into animal control because
it's not just
about dogs
um but but that's at the next stage so
um if
when we get to adopting the fees and
charges
uh we look to amend them and keep them
at the 2122 level i think that's a
reasonable outcome following some of the
discussions that came from last week
thank you sir
yes i'd still like to see um
some long-term
issues that
we can use to
solve this problem in a long-term way
um and
i know that a similar
issue arose
when i was mayor of waitamata city
and
what we did there was
let the people stay there
it was on ringato
and
and
well another cornwallis
and
they could only stay there
and there would be no rent collected of
them or rates i should say
sorry sir that's my fault for drawing a
comparison to cooper's creek
um it was merely just hold it but that's
not actually what we're discussing uh
it's the the dog fees but i think
because cooper's creek is an example of
where council has decided to park things
that's the similarity with what we're
doing with dog fees which is
the issue at the moment
i can just say i i would second what um
councillor ludlow and staff have
suggested there about the dog bees
remaining at the previous level that
does seem the eminently practical
and common sense thing to do at this
point that gives us time to work on some
further research
now thank you worship um
so the the one hundred and six thousand
six hundred and eighty three dollars in
unpaid dog registration does that stay
on our books as a positive
um as a plus and does that
how long does it stay there for
until it
till it's deemed unrecoverable and
obviously impacts on the
funding of that department
um through
your worship the
we will hold
that for another six to nine months to
try and recover it
and then um
i remember rightly it goes by the
ministry of justice for collection
because it's far away
by law
we need to investigate but we don't have
huge amounts of write-offs traditionally
in that area
okay so we don't see it as a because
that would impact dramatically on
obviously a budget
yeah
thank you
thank you yes councillor
just to follow on from that um if we do
an investigation on the finance team
about the reserves
that are sitting in the animal services
which are a targeted rate
if they're artificially high because we
haven't been coding the right sort of
cost to animal services
it would seem to me that we don't have
an ability to adjust that because it
runs across multiple years not about you
know what finest people think about that
so you know if we've got some costs
sitting in the gym i think a good
example is save ram take you might get a
car repaired
they could sit in
repair and maintenance of vehicles or it
could sit over against animal services
if the vehicle belonged to animal
services but it's really robbing peter
to pay paul in some ways
all it'll do is give us a clearer
picture of what the true
true reserve is and that's the most
important thing i think because it then
begs the question if the reserves are
reasonably high
then why would we push the rates up
given it's a targeted rate
that's one of the complications
counselor that we're still working
through
okay
thank you any further questions
discussion um
mr mayor i wonder whether councillor
ludlow wishes to
note either here or at the time of
adoption of the annual plan
a request to delay the implementation of
the advertised
fees for
dogs um
i i think through you your worship will
will do that when it comes to adopting
annual plan
another minute to the black community
board
now move on to item 10 the minutes of
the bluff community board
i'm saying
you worship just one moment
no no okay so councillor ludlow moved
the adoption of sorry the receipt of
those minutes and the second was
council romansen but it's for you to now
put that much in your workshop
there being no further discussion i'll
put it to the vote call them favor say
aye
against
carrick
minutes of the bluff community board
meeting held on the 20th of june
i've moved those minutes your worship
pro forma i was not at the meeting but i
did put an apology
because i had intended to be there
thank you
speaker worship councillor arnold was
present at the meeting it would be
more correct for councillor arnold i'm
sorry councillor lewis
um i'm sorry i
i didn't see council arnold up here i'm
sorry thank you
the minutes of the bluff community
brought out on the 20th of june
2022.
i think councillor arnold is
i'm not sure his volume is working but i
think i saw him suggest that he would
move those
yes i heard him do that
okay are you second to get in i would
second that performer thank you
thank you i'll put it to the boat all in
favor say aye
the minutes of the black
community board held on the 20th of june
2022
you received
the adoption of the 2022
2023 annual plan
cure your worship counselors
so bringing forward to you now the
annual plan for 2022-23
for adoption following consultation and
your deliberations on this matter
so this report outlines the
changes that you have
decided to make since the time of
consultation it notes
that there will be an unbalanced budget
for the 22 23 year and that is a result
of the timing of subsidy funding from
government and the on current forecast
the budget will return
to balance in 23 24.
i will just note under the financial
implications section just for
clarification
um
the rates affordability
benchmark
it lists that as rates revenue to 7.1
percent so just to note that it's
different that is the rates revenue
including growth that is different to
the average rates increase which is 6.53
so just for your clarification and
information
um
so happy to take any questions
yes
thanks your worship uh just a question
of clarification for a start this is
where we would make an uh an amendment
to the scheduler fees correct
good
um so your worship i'm happy to re uh to
move the um
five recommendations
uh
that are there but with
um
the addition of a sixth point which i've
just emailed to you miloveca
that council resolved to leave the
proposed advertised dog registration
fees for 2022-23
at the same level as for 2122
i'll second that your worship
thank you
thank you i've got a range of questions
um on
page 58
i guess this will be for britain
oh sorry on the pre-sitting page
um
it talks about the governor's subsidy
revenue
and um i'm still ultra confused about
this and i know we've been over this
several times but i'd like to get some
clarity to it
so on page
58
of boardwalks she talks about the
government subsidy and how that council
clark can you just remove your
microphone i'm struggling to hear you so
i'm not sure about those ones yeah um so
page 58 refers to uh
in the situation of the unbalanced
budget
um
and um and yet on page 59 it talks at
the top of the page
about our ability to actually um
move funding or revenue across the end
of a financial year
and so i don't understand how if we get
in simple terms that we get ten dollars
in this year
and we only spend eight of it and we're
going to spend two next year while we
don't do a
contingent liability across the end of
the year so we have a balanced budget in
both years so the first first issue on
the second issue is
on page 59 it also refers to um in the
top paragraph the the imbalance
even even when we do spend the money
there'll be a an imbalance or negativity
of 1.798 million
and so um i'll be interested to know why
that is because
i would have thought that if we get ten
dollars and we spend ten dollars it's
neutral if we get get ten dollars and
spend eleven dollars
well that that increase can only be
driven by we're spending more than we
have funded for or alternatively we've
got inflationary impacts that are
reasonably steep
okay um through your worship
the answer to that is that the 1.798
million that's referred to at the page
top of page 59 and board books
we had planned to receive that cash
next year in the 22-23 year
what's actually happened is we've
received it in the
21-22 financial year
and we've spent it in the 21 22
financial year
so therefore we have matching of our
income and our expenditure
in the current financial year but we've
lost the income from next year
just some follow-up questions your
worship um
so i think you referred in one of the
previous sessions here patricia that um
the following further
assessment by the finance team that you
identified that we received and spent
the money in a single year
so i don't understand if that's the case
how we've got an imbalance at the end of
the year or how we have an imbalance for
the fine year
so the reason we have the imbalance in
the following year is that we've lost
the income that we planned so when we
set the ltp we thought we were going to
have three waters money in the 22-23
financial year
that's no longer the case and we're
going to have all that money in the 21
22 financial year
so two follow-up questions that you wish
so if we've got the money earlier than
we forecast then the only thing wrong is
the forecast
and forecast can be it can be adjusted
in financial settings
surely if we've got it early and we've
spent it early
then that's fiscally neutral
if we've got it early and we haven't
spent it till the following year
whatever we haven't spent should be
carried across the end of the financial
year it can't just be put aside as a
surplus one year
and get pushed away into a into a bank
account
um i mean it's it's accounting 101 from
the advice i get that
you know if you have using a simple
scenario again ten dollars coming in
and you can't do all all ten dollars
worth of work in one year you do eight
and then you have two kicking into the
next year you just transfer the money
across the end of the fiscal year and
auditors accept that i don't know why we
don't do that
so
i'll remind so this isn't matching of
income and expenditure it's matching of
income against operating expenditure
and what we're actually spending this
three waters money this government
subsidy money is on capital which isn't
part of the formula for this benchmark
i've done it to myself there we go
um
i guess the
my question is is the difference the
fact that we're measuring this against a
long-term plan rather than an annual
plan so it's not about what's happening
in the one year we're being audited
about what we said we were going to do
over the three years and reporting
against the difference across those
three years correct council
just one final question on that then and
i'll move on um
so
to my way thinking it doesn't matter
what year the money comes in and what
year we spend it if we spend what we're
funded for then that must be fiscally
neutral in the overall big picture be
that the long-term plan and i can
remember quite carefully that when we
were discussing rates going up to seven
point seven percent one of the questions
that uh councillor sober asked quite
rightly was if we've got an unbalanced
bad budget and we push a further level
of unbalance into it is that have a
really negative effect going forward and
the answer was yes and i still i still
struggle with that
um so
[Music]
if we if we're getting ten dollars in
and we're doing ten dollars work with
across one year two years three years
surely that doesn't have our bottom line
somewhere along the line it's got to
balance out
your response to that
it balances out when you take both your
operating expenditure and your capital
expenditure together
but the balanced budget benchmark only
requires us to look at our operating
expenditure
so that's where why we can have an
imbalance in one year and an excess in
another year over the three years or the
10 years of the ltp we remain balanced
but when we look at one year
individually we're not
okay
sorry i guess one of the other points
that was raised when the matter came up
at ppp sir was that
the difference with running this
unbalanced budget is that we know why
it's unbalanced there's no wishing and
hoping
we can show
where the excess came in and why it's
unbalanced rather than well we could run
an unbalanced budget and hope that
everything balances up at the end of
next year that's the stuff that the
audit will have some difficulty with
thank you
for your worship i'm not sure i'd agree
with that last statement
section 100
the local government act has five
criteria in which we can operate an
unbalanced budget and then if you can
call back a couple of minutes ago
councillor scott said he'd done a bit of
a ring round and found that there were
quite a few councils running unbalanced
budgets i mean forecasting and
forecasting expenditure and revenue is a
bit of a rule of thumb at the best of
times
we never seem to get 100 right and
on a 120 million operating budget to be
seeking to run an unbalanced budget of
1.5 million dollars is a very small
amount but it keeps the rates at four
percent which is what we indicated to
the public we would do uh less than a
year ago
so just i'll just leave that parked up
there on page um
page 70 of our board books we've got i
just want to clarify a couple of things
we've got refinements the annual plan
for 2022 23
and you've got a figure in there of
65.5 million dollars and so i see that
that covers the new build for the museum
and the storage facility just wanted to
clarify what's the cost of the storage
facility in justin ball park figures
um
excluding any subsidy and um any
third-party contribution in point two
million that's important yeah thank you
cancer edmondson did you
yes i've got a range question sorry your
worship
um
on page 71 uh there's a comment in there
in regards to the um
project management office that was put
in some time ago to in order to assist
the improvement of delivery of capital
programs so two things in relation to
the project management office
i'm not sure whether you can do this
professional somebody else needs to do
it how many people in the office
and is is the cost going forward of that
um
overlaid by uh consultants or or
contractors as well
so i'm being told there's five people in
the
project management office and they use a
combination of
consultants as well as their own staff
okay thank you
and the last issue is the issue of the
storage um
tertiary storage facility
about six months ago i raised concerns
that i thought the time frame was too
tight
i think
evelyn also raised similar sorts of
things so i just wanted some
clarification from somebody around the
project management thing
where we're at with the tisbree storage
so do we have plans
um is the site to be prepared and
when will they build the new complex and
at what stage will we transfer the
collection so what's the end date for
that project
because in the report there it says at
one stage um it's a four year
four year uh project but then it says
it'll be done by the end of 2023 which
those two things don't quite tie up
um
steve's just going to come and
watch those particular ones
thank you through you
uh through your worship
um
counselor again if i can get you to
repeat those questions oh sure actually
answer them yeah just it was just really
the end date for the
i guess for the
process of getting plans preparing the
site
building the new complex in tisbury and
transferring the collection down
there's been some concern around
the time frames would be pretty tight
and given that the museum build the new
build is subject to getting that
completed i just
want to know what sort of time frame
we're looking at sure um so first off um
three chair
first off this decision is predicated on
you approving the annual plan today
and once you've given that approval our
program has a site establishment
commencing
december this year
and with construction completed november
next year
and as you've also been
receiving reports through the activity
management plan on the progress of the
collection packaging and ready for
relocation
we're approximately 91
of the way through and we're on track
there to achieve that
uh ready to relocate
from i would say late september next
year
so the collection will be in by november
you're predicting it the collection will
begin to be moved from
november december of next year
so previous advice that we got was that
that movement was a four month
activity
overall
3d chair
the program
is i'd say about six months okay six
months yeah that's fine
so just as a flow on from that because
this is all part of the one big one big
project
if we're looking about mid-2024
for the collection to be moved in
when will the main museum be open
constructed and open
as per the current time frame
it is
the first half of 2027. okay thank you
counselor
no i'm not sorry um on page 74.
so your worship um
we're actually at the point where we're
adopting the annual plan so the
questions that councillor clark is
asking
whilst i understand them and they are
relevant to the process really should
have been part of what we were dealing
with through ppps to previous meetings
were am i wrong
i i don't like to say anything
when you worship maybe i'd like to
comment towards that um some of the
information that we've previously
received has shifted in the annual plan
and certainly when we get on a little
bit further on we'll talk about snag
that's just come up recently and there
are issues there to be discussed as well
which
we haven't had previous does it does it
change the setting of the rates like
well
you know i mean when i seen a report
here
that our employee costs have gone up
from 27 million to 30 and a half million
which is up 15
i've not heard that before
not seeing that and you know i'd draw
three things um and so
this is the last opportunity i get to
ask those questions but his worship
decrees otherwise i'll just
any further questions discussion answers
yeah just a comment
two two actual comments actually so
following on from councillor clark
then i actually never raced this before
because i got so focused on
solid waste was
the increase of wages due to minimum
minimum wage and living wage now
i would have thought
that these calculations have been around
a while prior to us sitting the ltp
and it came as a bit of a shock
why they're actually
why they're there as something new
for the annual plan and i thought
that that living wage
and the calculations associated with it
would have been factored in for the next
full foreseeable future
um through you you worship so just to
clarify that all of that information was
provided to the public at the time of
consultation and it related to decisions
policy decisions made by government
following the completion of the
long-term plan but prior to consultation
on the annual plan so this is not a
change in any of the information to what
was consulted on at the time
of the consultation which was back in
march
and can i just follow up with that uh
because council is not
uh
part of the living wage
uh is not a living wage employer it is
an icc fair wage employer which is
impacted upon by the increase in the
minimum adult wage
but i just want us to be clear about the
terminology
okay
and my second comment is just regarding
again the increase of 700 000
uh
could have been and i still believe
could have been subsidised
through the ets
libby's using our waste net reserves
i'll stand by that comment and i will
not be supporting the adoption
of the plan
because of that
yes it's one final question
um
and it's on page 97 of board books
it refers there to employee costs
increasing from 27.2 million to 30.6
million which is up 3.5 3.4 million or
15 increase
now we've already had staff approach us
in the early stages of the annual plan
to suggest about the living wage which
is what we've just finished discussing
but that increase to that living wage or
the city council equivalent thereof
was nowhere near three and a half
million dollars so it begs the question
given that we've got vacancies
and that was part of the presentation by
staff to reduce
the rate cost down from 7.7
um
just like some explanation about why our
um our costs are going up by 15 surely
that cannot be
the cost that's being imposed upon
individual staff by way of an annual
wage increase
so council this is a combination
the other than this the amount which was
um
taken out for vacancies in the previous
discussions at ppp this is consistent to
what you've seen at consultation as well
um this does factor in some vacancies
but it also factors in all there's a
step change in the number of in the
organization since they are
ltp
part of this cost as well
so it isn't it's still consistent to
what you saw at consultation there
hasn't been anything added in since
other than the removal
of
the um vacancies that we discussed at
ppp
three units of worship and i'll probably
get off my side by saying what i'm about
to say
that was an answer that told me
absolutely nothing now it may have come
up before and it might be my area that i
haven't considered but yeah one of our
biggest line entries that we can manage
in our offering cost is personnel costs
and i've asked every quarter for the
last 11 quarters for a breakdown of
personnel costs and i've got it once and
it wasn't worth the paper it was written
on
um and so um
you know it it's my it's mind-boggling
to me why our costs go up by such a
large amount and i can't get a straight
answer for nearly three years
on why our personal costs tend to
escalate by anywhere between two and
three and a half million dollars a year
and i'll just leave that statement sit
there don't ask him to won't ask him to
respond to that
yes
um your worship
i find it difficult that we have waited
until today
to have this discussion again because it
seems like three or four months ago we
had this very same discussion
we cannot control
the minimum living wage is set by the
government
and we might predict all we like but
over a period of years
we can get it wrong we can't
second-guess the government they make
their decision that impacts everything
down the line
i would be
very disturbed
if i heard us
talking about treating staff less well
because costs have gone up that's a
reality if we value the people who work
for us then we have to meet
what is fair and reasonable in the
market and that includes when we recruit
it's a really tough market to be
recruiting in and that affects
also the amount of money that we have to
pay out in wages or salaries so
whilst i recognize that it would be nice
if the increase was less
we are living in
2022 with everything that has come down
the turnpike at us
we need good quality staff who want to
be
here working for us and having
conversations like this that are
directed at our
our most valuable asset which is our
staff is deeply deeply disturbing
thank you
your worship ms cook makes a very good
point and i think at this stage it may
be best that we move on with actually
voting and if necessary i will move the
motion that we go to the vote
well that hands were up before that
function thank you worship and as a
response to evelyn's comment which i do
support
that's not what i was asking
i identify any counselor sitting around
this table to answer two questions about
the personnel costs and correct me if
i'm wrong how much have we spent on
consultants
contractors and legal fees in the last
12 months and how much is built into
this annual plan for the future going
forward now i've asked and asked and
asked this this is not about tagging
staff or give them good pay increases or
not but we have a whole lot of hidden
costs
which we just don't want to look at
so hands up anybody who knows those two
answers
great
you wish if i can have a crack at that
part of it anyway
um
apart from
what's going on with
minimum wages or living wages
the entire job market is
saturated
and recruiting has become
um
quite a challenge
um so from that perspective in order to
attract staff
salaries
uh packages flexibility all these things
have have
i guess changed the marketplace
and we need to be able to compete with
that at the same time whilst we're
running a large number of vacancies
council still has a significant amount
of work that needs to be done and in
order to do that we've had to contract
in consultants
to to fill those gaps is it
as cheap
no
it's not but either the work piles up or
we get somebody to to help us through it
sometimes we have been the organization
that's contracted out our staff to
assist um other councils but that's just
what's going in the market
we went through um a pretty rigorous
process
starting i guess about four years ago
where we um
uh
reviewed staff activity um we looked to
trim in some areas and and and bolster
and others and this is
it sounds good and i don't mean it to be
counselor but it's just actually where
the market's at at the moment it's it's
not something
we've
seen before we had a brain gain going on
for two years and now that's just
suddenly flipped and that the borders
are open people are heading
back to wherever they were
um
that's
part of the answer to what the uh what
counselor clark was asking
all right well i think we've had a good
view of that
the tissues raised by guns but
and um
and that's known as a closure motion you
you need to deal with that to see
whether there is a second second or for
that closure motion
for that
oh
okay we've got a mover and seconded that
the motion be put
call them failed to say aye
aye
so i'm sorry your worship you've put a
closure motion
and you've
and and the standing order says that
needs to be put as soon as it is
uh and you're satisfied that that motion
passed by a majority
so you now need to put the motion of the
annual plan adoption which has been
moved and seconded
yes i moved it a counselor moved it and
he moved that additional has it does it
have a second gun
your side seconded
your worship
yeah it's been moved and seconded and
i consider after a period of robust
dialogue and discussion
uh
i think you've got to have transparency
in dealing with major
um you haven't given us the opportunity
to discuss the motion
once
who hasn't spoken moves that the motion
be put standing orders requires that you
put you deal with that motion if that
motion passes by a majority then you
then need to put the substantive motion
which is the adoption of the annual plan
that's what you've done
and councillor clark is is querying that
but that's the
an effect that's the impact of the
what's known as a closure motion that
the motion be put
right
you've put places in your worship
so
i want my vote recorded that i don't
support the annual plan
are we gonna have a
proper
vote or you know
actually yeah i didn't hear anyone ask
her against
sorry
i didn't hear that
you didn't hear what
obviously
when you put a motion you you call for
those in favor
and those against sorry your worship i
didn't hear
those against
being requested
okay
so we can go back to the original
i don't know how you could record your
worship
i think the issue might be that you
called for the vote and before you have
a chance to ask the against council cut
um called a point of order so i think
the state may be um
before the vote again and then
those who wish to report a vote against
will have their chance
okay
so do we put the boat
out
and this is just to be clear
your worship this is the vote
relating to the annual plan the adoption
of the annual plan
okay so that's the one that's on screen
behind
in front of you you worship and behind
me
well i'm glad to say hi
no
no no no
okay move on to the next stage of
business
could the question be asked whether the
people wanted to have their names
recorded against that
[Music]
happy to record them if requested
counsellor yes i'd certainly request
[Music]
your microphone's not working although
it's on
[Music]
reception on the beach
did you wish your vote against were you
voting against
yes and would you like your vote against
recorded
it's full liberating
he's ordering a pizza
so
for clarity can i ask what the vote was
it wasn't a show of hands
counsellor so
it was
determined by his worship on voices
that the vote was in the majority
with four recording opposed
i believe three
councillor clark i believe yourself
councillor kit and councillor arnold and
council upon you
i sorry to councillor potten did you
request your vote against to be recorded
i just imagine if you were recording the
nays you'd do a complete nade count but
if
yeah no i'll put my name down as well
please
thank you for that
okay
moving on to the draft
statement of intent
so the
city charitable trust
i think we have to do the setting of
rates first oh my apologies that's my
mistake
your worship i'm sorry i moved you on
too quickly
receiving the breaks
that
received the report of the setting of
rates for 20 22 23
having set out the rates
in worship i'm happy to move the two
motions as laid out in the agenda oh
secondly sir
yeah
you're looking at
both those items yes sir
having set out the rates of information
on the funding impact
statement and revenue and financing
policies
contained in the 2022-23
annual plan
and
he adopted his in an earlier paper of
this
meeting
resolved to set out the rates
outlined below
under the local government rating act of
2002.
for the
20
20 to 23 financial year
commencing
first of july
2022 and ended on 30th of june
2023
you're moving that council of ludlow
secondly for that yes
any discussion questions
for the division
called cancel the publisher
um it's just a comment really around um
looking at the
the rates for
water supply and wastewater supply and
stormwater
take a good look at them because you'll
never see these as low again
how many
youth councillors attended the meeting
which
the keynote speaker was
um peter williams
okay well
i found it really enlightening
and
managed to get the facts pretty well
sorted out in a way that
you weren't an entity you can still
understand them
so where are we up to now
i believe that motion's been moved and
seconded but i don't think you've put it
your worship
the client's got a question
i'm not going to be a pace of this
because it's it's just an example to do
that i've already been opposed to the
original setting of the rates at 6.53
and this is just a flow-on effect of how
that rate increase will impact across
the range of rates
i've seen a benefit in doing that even
though i am opposed to the overall rate
increase
i'll move the motion people
taking that
questions
put it to the bathroom and play to say
he um the council
receives a report draft statement of
intent
and became the city
of the middle territory
did we just jump yeah
there had been no real debate on that
item so i don't actually think it was a
closure motion but you've have at least
considered the item
um
i'm comfortable i devoted yes
i think his worship has moved the the
meeting on to the matter of the draft
statement of intent
and i think he's moved it and councillor
sopa has seconded it
[Music]
the council receives a report
draft statement of intent
southland museum and art gallery
the gallery transport
to
that council make the following comments
to smack
that smack provide
confirmation
that the staff draft statement of intent
meets legislative requirements
in
relation to non-financial
performance targets and measures
and that
smag
consider whether the title of
section 3 of the statement of intent
should read outputs planned
for the year ended 30th of june
2023 not
2022.
that's just a typo
uh i think that the typo occurs within
the draft statement of intent and
rather than officers being able to
change it they've pointed it out yes
thank you questions
counselor clark uh page 139 which is the
um statement of intent at the very top
in in the bowl red areas is um
the review of the governance of smack is
currently underway as any changes of the
government structure are currently
unknown is that a typo
because it seems to me all the way
through the port there are changes to
who's actually on the board now
your worship
it's
it's half a typo
if that doesn't sound
um
some of the changes have been reflected
in the draft statement of intent as
councillor clark has picked up
and the trustees that are on the smag
board are now
um
[Music]
in place but there are still
assumptio there is an assumption
in terms of what this trust is
responsible for because the activities
of the southland museum have now come
into the council as part of its core
activity
and the smag trust is now a
collection-centric trust and there
hasn't been the opportunity because of
the legislative time frames there hasn't
been the opportunity to conclude
all of the changes that should take
place
best reply i've had laughs
so
going back to that then why would we
take a statement of intent now
that clearly has some unknowns for us
because once you get down to page 146
it talks about the role of the board
which is a smart board is responsible
for the governance of smag which smack
meaning south of museum and art gallery
and i would like to know in the
statement of them what does that
actually mean given that we own the
museum well
what's left of the museum we own the
land and we're responsible for employing
the
museum manager and all the staff and we
wear most of the costs
and i i would be nervous if we were
going back to what we had before where
we were we were held to account by a
board that we had no control over your
worship you're not going
to a place of being held to account by a
board you have no control over
uh i can say that with
um
real com real conviction on the basis of
the three chief executives
the real point here though is
um
[Music]
it's going i'm sorry i've lost my train
of thought it's going to be
collection-centric but your we
collectively are stuck between two
devils
audit new zealand telling you that you
haven't received the statement of intent
in the time frame that you need it
or getting it fully correct before you
receive it
and we the management felt that it was
more appropriate audit are less
concerned with its contents
and more concerned with the process the
legislative time frame
so we felt it was more important that we
got the draft to you so that you could
provide some commentary
and it can then be finalized
and you will receive it in its final
form
and that gave the new trustees the
opportunity to work through the
more accurate statement of intent for
future years
you worship if i can add to that and
just say there's there's not a huge
amount of difference between this
scenario and what we had in in the
previous year because we realized at
that stage that the
the previous trust board was
transitioning into a new structure so we
adopted a statement of intent that was
not incredibly dissimilar to what would
run the previous year and again audit
were comfortable with that knowing that
it wasn't necessarily an accurate
reflection of what we were going to be
doing over those 12 months but more that
we had gone through the process and
given stakeholders the chance to
feedback it's the same now so we have
three temporary trustees four sorry
temporary trustees my apologies reverend
cook
and they will go through a recruitment
process yet to come and
as the chief executive says it's now
a collections centric board which means
they are not involved in the operation
of the museum their duty of care is
around the collection
thank you
just two quick questions for the chief
executive so the final form
you said is when
sorry the final form of the statement of
intent sure
um the trustees will see it again on
friday
and will receive council's comments and
any other comments from other
councils that have received this
i fully expect that it will be worked
through
over the coming months so that we are in
a better position for
the following year's
statement of intent
just a final reflection i guess one of
the things i would hate us to go back to
is where people in the city felt
that we were
um the dog being wagged by the tail as
it were or the other way around
whichever way he goes
that we had little no control because we
have a
governance board that sits above us that
can influence
where we go
your worship i want to make it really
clear to all elected members that you
the elected members of invercargill city
council
are the board responsible for the
performance of the southland museum in
future thank you
[Music]
i know your worship i think that
motion's been moved and seconded but it
now needs to be put no it hasn't been
moved in second oh my apologies
i'm happy to move those recommendations
no it's actually
secondary to the boat all on favor say
hi
again
and there is no urgent business in
public your worship
so
just thank
you um media for their attendance here
tonight
um logan you're
you're a veteran of this
council chamber and we appreciate your
now the public excluded session
moved and seconded that publicly
excluded
from the following parts of the
proceedings
of this meeting namely
confirmation of minutes
public excluded session of council held
on the 24th of may
2022
receiving the minutes of the public
excluded session
of the
infrastructural
services services committee
held on the 7th of june 2022
receiving the minutes of the public
excluded session of risk and assurance
committee held on the 14th of june 2022
the receiving of minutes of the public
excluded session
of the performance policy and
partnership committee
held on the 14th of june
in the chief executive officers
performance review
i'll move that where are your worship
i'll take a look
thank you it's been moved and seconded
any discussion questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
you